إنها نفس
التقنية مثل البوق ولكن ليس
لديك أي
أزرار للضغط ، ما عليك سوى فعل ذلك
بفمك وبهوائك ، أنا تيم لين ، أبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا وأقوم بتشغيل الألبورت الذي
بدأته عندما  كنت في السادسة من
عمري ، والدي صيني وأمي
من بيلو لكنني ولدت في ألمانيا
وجبال الألب ليست شائعة هناك
[موسيقى]
أحيانًا يأتي الناس إلي ويسألونني
كثيرًا من الأسئلة ،
على سبيل المثال من أين أنت ولماذا
هل تعزف على الآيبورن
بالنسبة لبعض الناس ، إنه مجنون حقًا بالنسبة لي ،
فأنا أعزف بقلب أحب هذه الآلة
الموسيقية والموسيقى التي
تشربها ويلز مهرجان نقي في هوندا
هو اجتماع دولي
لمشغلي الألبوم أفضل
اللاعبين في العالم يأتون
إلى هنا للتنافس والأخير  في العام ، فزت بالجائزة الأولى
في فئة العصير
في مهرجان iphone أشياء أخرى
هنا
يرقص الثعلب نوعًا من المصارعة
ولكن الشيء الأكثر أهمية هنا هو
لعب iporn
معظم اللاعبين من سويسرا ولكن
هناك أشخاص يأتون من
ألمانيا اليابانية  مثلي أو الولايات المتحدة
أثناء المنافسة ، هيئة المحلفين عمياء
لذا فهم يجلسون في خيمة ولا يرون شيئًا
هم هنا فقط
عندما ألعب كيف أصف
أه أشعر بأنني محظوظ ، أشعر بأنني
ألعب في الجبال إنها تجربة رائعة
لأنها  لا أحد لديه مثل هذا الرأي
لك